here with Karen Ashley the second yellow
ranger for money more from power rangers
how's it going it's going great i'm
still happy to be in chicago and so
happy to be at c2e2 so it's awesome
awesome we wanted to ask you a couple
questions um it's been over 20 years
since Power Rangers came out that I mean
it's been a long time I was two years
old then so you know it's good to enjoy
the show as an adult no it's been it's
been a long time and it's been an
amazing 20 years uh what does it like to
come to these events and see all these
these fans who grew up watching you and
now you are getting to meet them in
their adult phase was it like for you
it's so amazing because ok first first
thing is they walk up and they become
five years old again so that it's like I
don't really get to meet them as adults
because they revert back to five years
old but it's amazing I can't believe
that the show is still relevant it's
still a huge part of their lives and i
just can't believe the support that we
get it's it's mind-blowing so I'm so
humbled and so blessed to have all of
them in my life absolutely um so there's
a Power Rangers movie coming out another
one yes um do you have any involvement
in it whatsoever we get this question
almost every week not not as of right
now no so who knows I'm hoping that the
powers that be will be nostalgic and
give us a nod we did the original movie
but um I don't know I just hope it's
good for you I hope it's good for the
fans and I'm sure Lionsgate is gonna
give you guys an amazing movie I'm
excited about that new cast and I just
think it's great i love it the franchise
keeps growing is there anything else
that you have going on filming wise or
anything like that yeah yeah i'm
actually working on a movie this year I
can't talk about it just now but you'll
hear about it and may first it everyone
the whole world will know about this
movie but yeah I do that I do obviously
the comic cons I have my web series
uncensored talk um so yeah there's a lot
going on 2016 has not failed me it's
been a good year very
very good year well thanks for joining
us real appreciate the interview thank
you take care